welcome to this video playing a cowboys
in the house played him very often eight
times I've got eight games here in the
in the statistics scoring seven wins and
one loss so I've got a very good score
against the sky so let's see if this is
an opportunity to regain some that some
lost rating points that I don't really
know strange line let special g5 and
Bishop b5 if I kobish up d7 young maybe
he's got to be five I don't know but I
should be able to take here right but
should be five ef ef this should be okay
he does not have Queenie to check out
I'm protecting that the bishop is not
bad here I'm not sure what is smooth as
maybe he still should take on b5 yeah
and now I'm grabbing here this is really
strange check her half here comes the
check yeah well 27 runs into 96 check I
wonder i still wonder if I baby should
do that king of a it is also not not
especially great he can castle long this
is a problem hmm
yeah well I can play super materialistic
okay let's try that maybe I'm getting
completely destroyed now it is possible
this is what I'm talking about g-form
now come on I'm trying that if yeah this
is the problem of course maybe maybe
Queen 56 okay let's let that take you
first let's take you first I have quit
have six actually this could be
important here Queen f6 so if he takes
on b7 I'm taking be to with a big check
hmm but King de to what's my next move
push-up age six check maybe that's
completely wacky disposition Queen a sex
queen bees mmm
yeah I probably need to do that check
here we go I actually have bishops III
I'm just seeing that now it cannot take
because of the pin which does not
necessarily mean it it's a good move
mm-hmm I can my original intention was
this check and King g7 yeah come on let
me that the the point is that if he
takes the rook I'll take the the the
night and ok you can play rook be one
maybe I don't have a check ok as a six a
move no it isn't
okay let's let's do that let's do it
it's some khaki rupee Wonderstone you
will prolly and what now where can I
deal with the Queen need to need a good
square for the Queen if it takes I must
I must be able to will have 97 with the
tempo anyway and then 95 okay let's go
here it's impossible to to calculate
already with the to it one minute I have
not 95 and 95 now very dramatic position
can go to eat to wear this this is
really a shame i gave against any to
Queen a five maybe Queen f5 is the way
to go mar 25 you'll play Queen d5
probably 25 night somewhere see 5 or if
I'm at is going to eat too I have rope
yet I have appeared i still have this
rook we had to go here this is blocking
i don't believe in that move okay check
it really low on time
check 94 94 come on threatening Knight
d2 this is a big threat and Queen f2 of
course and if you place Queen Queen d4 I
can give the check i can give the check
in check winning the winning the rook
the whole look Wow yeah this is just a
piece amazing check check yeah okay this
is fortunately relatively easy
technically getting the edge bone white
version yeah somehow I I seem to almost
always win against the sky sometimes
it's nice to have the statistics to know
that ok i beat this guy before but i
have no idea what was going on here no
idea at all check k so he cancelled and
now yeah well g4 was very materialistic
of course but maybe it's working yeah
the compass pretty optimistic about
blacks chance it wants to play harm yeah
yeah the computer it wants to play Queen
f6 immediately yeah I briefly thought
about that but not really followed up on
that yeah this is in fact quite strong
it's the same idea but what is wide
smooth now after that for example I can
take a check check
yes someone I can even just develop
droopy aid and I'm having all the attack
here funny really funny yeah this was
much better than okay well this is still
good for blankets s night a six no okay
well this is half of course yeah they
are sometimes the solution is simple
here white can just exchanged a play 97
ok Mac queen bees happiness is a
tempting move of course we can take him
and play the smooth which um which is
probably to be preferred white has two
pawns yeah I'm not so sure about that to
be honest because this is a really
strong piece and the night might be able
to to come into the game to blockade
yeah yeah this is not so clear it's not
so clear when I didn't see any of that
but it's not so clear okay to check ya
know what's come of T 65 m yeah okay
it's what is the point at the point is
c4 I see ya okay well this this is clear
the chat that black asus is winning but
this is the point i have this movement
check and of course i didn't see that
now he has no good move needs to check
get into something like that and I mean
at the moment i'm a i'm a i'm piece up
hinge still needs to take something here
and I'm just attacking with King g7
Andrew get to the game yeah this was
funny okay thanks for watching